la historia se remonta al año 2012
cuando nicolas sarkozy competía por un
segundo mandato a la presidencia de
francia al ir perdiendo en las encuestas
amplió a gran escala sus fastuosos
mítines políticos al estilo
estadounidense
en total gastó más de 42 millones de
euros casi el doble del límite legal los
investigadores afirman que para ocultar
el gasto excesivo sarkozy se benefició
de un sistema de facturas falsas creado
por la empresa de comunicaciones big man
lyon dirigida por personas cercanas
agent françois copé uno de los
ejecutivos del partido de sarkozy 14
personas entre ellas sarkozy están
acusadas de la financiación ilegal de la
campaña otros que enfrentan cargos son
los ejecutivos del antiguo partido del
mp y los directivos de pigmalión la
mayoría de los acusados afirman no haber
estado al tanto de lo que ocurría sólo
cuatro de ellos en los que se encuentran
llegan la brilló el subdirector de la
campaña del ex presidente en ese tiempo
han reconocido parcialmente sus
responsabilidades ya descubrí el nombre
de big valley on muchos de la campaña
presidencial de la competencia
sarkozy siempre ha negado todas las
acusaciones la fiscalía solicitó una
condena de un año y seis meses de cárcel
obligatoria y una multa de 3.750 euros
los magistrados criticaron la ausencia
de sarkozy durante su juicio en las
cinco semanas de audiencia el
expresidente sólo compareció una vez sin
importar la sentencia de este jueves
sarkozy tendrá derecho a apelación